hey steve how are you man
uh
is that is that mark from uh battle of
the planets it is
oh very good
i wish we were doing this at my uh from
my home i've got a great uh a great one
i'll send you a picture
yes um also half the reason i keep those
there is because i figure at some point
someone i speak to is going to be like
that's great ip that has not been done
we should make that
i i hope that happens i hope that
happens but anyway
so um i think you're in an interesting
position that i believe if you probably
um can make whatever you want to make
next but
if you can get the financing to make
anything you want what would you make
and why
oh my god steve we're starting with that
question oh yeah
jumping right into the deep end
um
do you mean like ip or just yeah it's
like more like the dream project like
maybe you have a script in the desk that
like no one has ever paid for you know
what i mean like the one like you know
it's like an excuse to talk about
something you've always wanted to make
sure uh well i wrote uh i wrote a draft
of um of a role-playing game that i
loved as a kid called riffs rafts as a
palladium game
and uh it's probably the best script
i've ever written and uh
and i don't think it'll ever be made but
if i could make anything if i could wave
a magic wand that would be uh kevin
zembeda's
riffs rafts
this is what i'm talking about it's a
perfect excuse to you know air that
script you know what i mean yeah for
sure man uh if someone has never seen
anything that you've directed what's the
thing you want them starting with
oh god um
i don't know i think red notice i think
it's my best film
okay um
uh before i jump into red notice um you
are attached to the division uh which is
something that i am i mean it's been
talked about for forever do you think
it's actually getting made anytime soon
i do actually uh i love the division i
i'm a huge fan i play it every tuesday
night with three buddies of mine like a
like a bowling league we've been playing
for i don't know
seven eight years now uh from division
one through division two and uh yeah i
think i i think we have a very good
chance of getting it made um we just uh
just finished our second draft uh
and i'm about to do my my pass on the
script i haven't had a chance to write
on it because i've been making this
movie uh so uh i'm hopeful that i'll do
my pass on the on the draft and then
we'll go make it this year it's it's my
it's my next movie as far as i'm
concerned
right that's what i wanted to know i
know that that has to be a priority
project for netflix um
have they made that clear to you like
please we really want to make this next
year
uh
they haven't quite said it like that but
uh but but you know we've been focused
on on red notice but it's definitely
something that they're excited about and
we're excited about
what do you my last thing on it what do
you think it is
uh about the material that will make it
a like a cool movie
well i mean i i i what i love about the
division the game itself is yes it's
it's super fun to play it's a
cover-based co-op shooter but the part
that i love most about it is and this
might sound a little corny but but when
you're on these missions in the game uh
you're there to restore power to get
electricity running to get people food
and water um so you're there to help
right you're there in service of and i
think that um
that the division has a great heart at
its center the core concept of that game
uh and it asks a very very simple
question uh what do we owe each other in
a society uh what does one person owe to
another uh when the chips are down and
things look at their worst are you are
you a self selfish person or are you a
selfless person
um and and how do we
rise together if at all and there's a
lot of powerful themes there i'm really
excited to explore so i think the
ultimately
um the heart
of that of the movie um the heroism of
the movie is what is what's gonna uh
drive it
if i'm not mistaken red notice was
originally set up at universal um
and then it went to netflix was there
any point that you're like oh maybe this
isn't going to get made
uh yeah i mean i think i always think
that steve i always go like gosh we're
never going to make this thing
until we're actually shooting um maybe
it's just sort of the sort of um cynic
in me i suppose but uh
but i you know it was never a lack of
belief in in the idea or the or or the
the script frankly or or the the
elements um but you always you know when
you're dealing with a film at the scale
with these big stars it's always tricky
you know and these things fall apart
very easily everybody's very busy you
know it's a it's certainly a large
investment and um yeah it can be really
tricky there's there's no
you know i think it's a miracle when any
movie gets made
i've heard that from every single
director is there an element of
the fact that it's coming out on netflix
is there an element that you sort of
like i'm glad i don't have to worry
about what the weekend box office
numbers are you know like yeah oh
absolutely yeah it's it's it's uh it's
my first netflix film and um and not
having the
opening weekend box office and the
tracking that leads up to it hanging
over your head is um it's it's just the
most lovely thing yeah
yeah i'm i have i'm gonna go out there
on a ledge and say this will be the
number one movie on the number one thing
on netflix once it premieres i don't
know where i'm getting that data from uh
but i'm confident in this uh in this
guesswork oh thank you steve i hope so i
hope so like that's that's what we came
here to do
yeah there's
no doubt um how did you come up with the
idea for the mcguffin
oh uh thank you for using the phrase and
thank you for asking well well um yeah i
i wanted uh i wanted something
that had a little bit of history to it a
little bit of mystery to it and um and i
you know i couldn't find anything that i
that i liked i wanted to have make sure
there were three of them for each in an
act and um
and i couldn't quite find anything and
so i made it up um and i and i loved uh
uh i was a classics minor uh in college
and i've always been fascinated uh you
know uh
by egypt and egyptology and all of that
and certainly the the the marc anthony
julie caesar cleopatra love triangle i
thought sort of interesting and um and
so i just kind of wedged this macguffin
into actual history and what was really
fun steve is when i was pitching
uh the idea i would go through and i
would talk about cleopatra's eggs as
though they were real
and and so often people go oh yeah yeah
yeah right cleopatra's eggs
and then at the end of the pitch i'd be
like oh by the way that was all [ __ ]
and i made it up and they would go ah
but it was fun it was fun to
to see them believe it
but the thing is like with ancient egypt
it this could be real you know it's not
it's not so far-fetched especially with
the you know with everything that went
on anyway that's you know um i want to
switch to something else was there did
you have to pull ryan and dwayne aside
multiple times and say listen guys
we're only going to use your liquor once
in the movie so pick a spot
uh no no it's a good question uh you
know it was something that uh that i
thought would be a fun little uh i
suppose easter egg uh for for fans of
ryan dwayne
and i tried to i tried to put it in
the film in a in a subtle or classy way
um and uh but but i did promise that i
would that you know you couldn't do one
without the other you can't you're not
going to put dwayne's in and not ryan's
or vice versa so uh fair play across the
board
since no one is recording this and no
one is watching uh which do you think
tastes better
oh god you know i think they are both
disgusting i would not touch touch them
no i'm kidding
it's gonna be like wow that is great
steve i don't really drink so i i
couldn't i couldn't tell you um but uh
yeah i wish i had a better answer i
don't i don't drink
um one of the things is i'm curious
about this so you write your script
you get your cast you you know you go
out to cast and everyone's excited they
want to do it but every person i've
spoken to tells me that once cast signs
on then you're doing those rewrites to
accommodate for the actors that you have
assembled for your movie so i'm curious
how did the script change from what you
envisioned once dwayne ryan and gaul you
know signed on
sure well dwayne was on from the jump uh
i i pitched him first and he's like i
love it i'm in so i was always writing
with him in mind and having made two
movies with him before
uh there you know i mean there's always
tweaks and changes and moments but it
was largely what it is um for gal uh i i
you know in my little notebook as i'm
working through the ideas uh for red
notice i choose the only name i had and
i you know circled it twice and and i
flew to london to pitch her the idea and
i pitched it to her and she uh said yes
and she was in and then i wrote the
script and and ryan was the only person
i wanted for the for the role and so i
had his voice in my ear as i was writing
and i did my best to approximate it um
and then we sent him the script he's the
only person we sent the script to he
said yes the next day and we were off
and running now as you know it's a very
smart question of course as you go
you know the the the actors have ideas
and thoughts they have to play the
character typically they're they're
really good you know sometimes they're
you know they're just different um and
and i've learned to kind of embrace
those and try to find out you know
what's the note behind the note what are
they trying to accomplish and i try to
do my best to to to do that while still
serving the film uh as a as a whole uh
one thing on gal's character in the
original pitch uh it was much a much
smaller uh part
not not you know it wasn't that she
wasn't in it but it was just she was
more hidden throughout um it was a much
bigger reveal and you uh and and as i
was writing it
i just felt like oh gosh we can't we
can't have gal gadot in this movie and
and not
have her in this movie and so i we ended
up writing
more and more scenes for her and i'm so
glad we did to really balance it
um did netflix ask one of the things
about streaming is you can basically
release any runtime that you want i mean
movie could be an hour and a half it
could be two and a half hours did they
ask for a two hour movie or how did you
get to that run time no there was no no
discussion even once of runtime uh i'm
somebody who uh
likes to keep it tight and light fast
and funny uh so there's never really any
um
any concerns about length or pace is
maybe what you're talking about
so
you know typically with a comedy you're
under two hours anyways this has more
action than a straight comedy so i think
you know hour 45 hour 55
you know you're still you're still um
still in good stead
i couldn't imagine a two hour and 15
minute version of this movie
when you get in the ed when you got in
the editing room what was your first
like what was your director's cut length
or like did you have a version that was
220 and you're like oh [ __ ] how are we
going to get this down
no you know i think the first director's
cut um was
i want to say the director's cut
the editor's assembly was two and a half
then the director's cut was 210
if i'm remembering um and even in that
director's cut i mean it wasn't even
directions it was like like my first cut
was like 210
and then my process is i you know i show
it to very you know trusted friends uh
uh and allies and i and i keep honing
and keep keep uh uh trimming and cutting
and um we were under two hours really
really quickly um and kept kept going
from there i think if i was left alone
long enough in an editing room the film
would end up being about 38 minutes long
how many what was the last thing that
you cut out of the movie before you
picture locked and why
uh we cut out what the three
uh our three heroes are uh are off to
steal at the louvre
oh
that's interesting you decided to leave
that for your imagination yes sir
um did you were there a lot of other
deleted scenes or was it just the
trimming of fat in between scenes it was
mostly the trimming of fat um uh you
know or you know fat essentially
anything not not needed uh it was so
strange red noticed we had i don't know
maybe
three
little seamlets that didn't that that
don't that didn't make the final cut
which is i think the the least amount
i've ever had in anything i've made um
so it was mostly just about tightening
and trimming and keeping it keeping the
pace up
did you at any point because right now
obvi with marvel movies and with even
some of the other moves some other
movies people have been doing a lot of
after the credit scenes and you know or
putting in bloopers during the credits
or doing other stuff during the credits
was there ever any just did you ever
think about do we want to do something
during the credits
uh we you know
a little bit not not fully uh there's
never an idea of doing a tag at the end
of the credits uh you know we thought
about maybe doing some outtakes but um
you know when i looked at it it just
didn't feel right to me and i've done it
before i did it on miller's and i did it
on central intelligence and i i love you
know look i love outtakes or bloopers at
the end uh cannonball run probably the
high water mark for that uh invented it
i think and um and so uh yeah it was
never real really in consideration i
don't think the tone of this film would
would suit that
uh you're on set filming this uh which
is the sequence that you regretted
writing because it was such a pain in
the ass to pull off
oh man
let me let me think um
god there's one that's so specific and
i'm blanking on it
you know uh
oh it's just a small one you wouldn't
even notice it uh i'll pick a different
one um i you know i would say
i would say it was the the bullring was
actually
a a real pain in the ass
um and took forever um and and uh when
i'm there i'm like oh man
you know i could just cut to the train
we don't need this um but um but it ends
up being really fun in the movie one of
the things that ryan is obviously
exceptional at is delivering lines
like only ryan can
in the movie there's the line is this
farm to table uh look for the box that
says mcguffin um
are those things that you scripted is
are these things that ryan is coming up
with in the moment
oh sure uh well on those specific ones
from the table all ryan mcguffin was me
um but i think you know i think on
balance i would say
90 of what's in the film uh was written
and and a healthy 10 was was improv and
um and ryan is just great with that and
that 10 makes all the difference right
like those those great moments he's just
so gifted
at doing that and i've been such a fan
for so long that you know whenever ryan
was like maybe i could say this most of
the time i just die laughing and say
let's go um
because i get all the credit at the end
anyway steve so i i don't care
right 100 um when in the
third act uh in the vault if you will
ryan is whistling the indiana jones
theme
is that in the script was that something
he came up with and how much of a pain
in the ass was it to actually get
permission to put it in the movie god
this is such a smart question i know
nobody else is going to ask me that
that's that's uh that's why i love you
um so well it's something i came up with
uh on the day uh i pitched it to ryan
uh and he's like oh that's great let's
do it and then he's like wait a minute
can we do that i'm like let's just do it
we'll figure it out later um and so we
did it and then um
uh and then we called up uh essentially
john williams and and uh
and and the rights holders and uh and
and they've never done it before uh and
but but they did it this time they
allowed us to use it i was really
generous of them i was gonna say what is
it like making that phone call because
if they say no it's a great bit that's
just gone i know right so you're just
crossing your fingers and you know you
squeeze your eyes shut tight and you
just hope hope hope hope they they say
yes and um my music supervisor gabe
hilfer is um is is uh is relentless and
he's very convincing and uh and he makes
the call so basically like if they said
no to gabe then i would have called i
would have written a letter i would have
camped out in front of you know
stephen's house
uh uh and you know because you just you
don't want to lose a little bit of magic
like that um so it would have been a
long hard fight before i would have we
wouldn't have done it i think
uh talk a little bit about crafting the
third act sequence in the mind because
obviously there's a little bit of i mean
you have the the raider the indiana
jones theme and the
the vault is a little bit of a nod
towards in my opinion you know the
raiders vault um yeah just obviously um
so talk a little bit about crafting that
sequence because it's
not only is it a huge sequence but
you're filming it during a pandemic and
it's all being done in atlanta
and
it was a real challenge i mean certainly
like i grew up in the bay area in the
you know uh mid 80s and uh early 90s so
uh you know my entire childhood was
invented by steven spielberg and george
lucas so for me uh raiders uh is on the
mount rushmore of of of movies um and so
certainly a nod to that no surprise um
and i think you know shooting in atlanta
uh all of the stuff in atlanta was a
real challenge uh for the mineshaft
sequence we actually went to
a mine in northern atlanta uh that was i
think a limestone uh mine and we were
400 feet underground uh and shot uh
almost all of that sequence there uh so
we literally were underground for two
weeks shooting it and then we shot of
course all the movie stars um on on
stage and then you you put it together
um and it was it was you know you have a
storyboards at first i write it and we
storyboard it then we pre-visit um and
then you go shoot it uh and then you
realize oh no this doesn't work that
doesn't work and then you start cutting
it out and cutting it down and finding
what works and you know doing
a couple little quick pickup shots to
help stitch a couple
pieces together and then you have a
sequence
when you are writing your let's use the
third act as an example of the the mind
uh
the whole action set piece when you're
writing the script how descriptive are
you in the scripting phase of
writing out this action set piece and
how much is it on the page massive
mine shaft you know action set piece
ensues
yeah yeah yeah yeah
atlanta burns
um yeah no it's it's um
i when i write an action sequence i i
try to um
it's a communication tool right so i'm
trying to
uh evoke a feeling
uh
of the sequence i try to make sure that
i'm writing the key elements of story
that happen within the sequence uh so
that we're revealing character and plot
and then
um
and then i'm sort of a little looser in
terms of uh tone like you know it's a
big uh you know
big chase ensues uh as they jockey for
position
but then you kind of get into specific
beats that you need to tell your story
and from that
i go to storyboards and i work with
storyboard artists as we kind of you
know uh step through the entire sequence
and then he or she will come up with you
know pitches oh what if it does this
what if it does that you add those in
and then we have a great um uh previous
uh company uh called third floor and
they
they take that and they and then they
plus it up and they bring their ideas in
and some you like some you don't
and then you bring it to your stunt uh
coordinator and he looks at it and then
he adds or or takes away he or she
rather and um and and it's like that so
it's a layer cake of creative and idea
as you progress and then you have to
find the location and sometimes you
can't shoot the thing you wanted at the
location because there's not this
particular thing and then you have to
invent something new
so it's it's a it's a long long
complicated
delightful process so do you you're just
finishing up do you actually know what
you're going to do next or besides
taking a few weeks to just like
disappear
yeah i'd really like to take a break
this has been a long haul this has been
the most challenging film i've ever made
i think it's the best film i've ever
made like i said earlier um but it
really especially with the with
the global pandemic that struck right in
the middle of our shoot and shut us down
for six months so this has been a long
haul for everybody um and what i really
want to do just on a personal note is uh
to um just take a little time off rest
spend some time with my family uh
recuperate uh re-energize and then and
then saddle back up but but uh yeah the
next next thing on the docket for me is
the division i mean i can't wait
on that note i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say congrats um and you already know
this is gonna be a huge hit so
you're very kind i'm gonna keep my
fingers crossed i'm gonna send you i'm
gonna i'm gonna send you a picture of of
my uh
of my mark uh oh no dude you totally you
100
should i know the eggs are cool and
everything because it has to do with the
movie but you can't go wrong with like
you know stuff like that let's go you
know by the way i'm telling you it needs
to get made dude i'm i'm available tech
avail i'm unemployed
right i got to go i'll talk to you soon
man congrats you're the best
you